first era of smartphones are all like
this clean and simple but kind of
one-dimensional
so how do you differentiate when
everyone has essentially the same phone
like this or more to the point like this
Motorola's new phone the moto Z is the
result of a years long project to build
a modular smartphone one where you the
user gets to decide how it works and how
it looks
you can add speakers that actually have
some bass or a battery pack when you
know you'll be using your phone for
hours or a pretty decent projector and
Motorola achieved all this by giving
developers full access to the entire
smartphone functionality that includes
every connector and every chip so that
when you attach a mod it's not like
plugging in an accessory it's like
adding a new piece to your phone and
then securing it so that it feels like
one piece of first principle behind that
prototype was make something that is
truly thin and light to give it the
tensile strength that we needed to make
sure that the phone did not actually
Bend we have to reinvent a special kind
of steel on the back of the device to
make sure that we can actually build a
device that's 50% thinner than our
existing designs throughout the design
process Motorola had to rethink almost
every part of the smartphone engineers
had to move the antenna so your cell
service wouldn't be blocked by the boss
they also got rid of the headphone jack
and they came up with a way to use
magnets pins and even that big camera
home to make it really easy to attach
and detach models and they worked on
making it really really easy for other
people to make mods so we took a lot of
inspiration from grasper API and we were
able to come up with essentially a
full-blown board that a developer
doesn't have to build on their own it
has a cork board and you can build on
top of the board itself for your own
application and for all this to work
motorola needs to build a huge ecosystem
of mods and help people understand the
value of a modular phone in the first
place
which is harder than it sounds
really this is all one big grand
experiment but maybe it's also the next
best step for smartphones
the whole reason smartphones like this
are great is that their app stores let
you do a million things with your very
same device isn't it time our phones
themselves worked the same way